take you to some breaking news now out
of France where at least four children
and an adult have been injured in a
knife attack it happened in the town of
analsi in the French Alps the children
are all around three years old and two
of them are in a life-threatening
condition
police say the attacker is a Syrian
refugee with legal status in France and
he's been arrested president Emmanuel
macron has caused the attack an act of
absolute cowardice a moment of silence
was observed in the French Parliament or
let's speak to Natasha Butler she's in
the French capital for us Natasha what
more do we know about this attack right
now
yes really this is uh every parent
nightmare a man stabbing children
early morning police say that the attack
happened around 9 45 local time in
France and the Lakeside a city of anazi
at the foot of the eyewitnesses
described seeing a man climb over the
fence into this playground which is in
the middle of a park in the town and
they said they saw the man lunging at
some children where one one woman said
that she thought he was trying to play
with some of the children but then they
heard people screaming and running away
so really terrible scenes there uh in
anisee now what uh the French police are
saying is that they have arrested a man
he was trying to flee the scene after uh
this attack he is a suspect they say
that they found an identity paper on him
which said that it was he was a Syrian
Asylum Seeker that who gained asylum in
Sweden and but was based in France he
wasn't known though to the police so
terrible scenes there in this Alpine
city of anisee just awful Natasha I see
president macron has already spoken
about this it's obviously potentially
very politically sensitive I imagine
well I think at this stage there's just
more a sense of shock you know amongst
the public these uh playgrounds that are
in Parks you see them in every city in
every village in France you know in the
early hours of the morning it's summer
at the moment you know parents go out
with their young children their nannies
and carers the kids are in the sandpit
or on the slides the last thing that you
could imagine happening is the children
being vulnerable to this kind of
violence and this sort of attack and we
understand that at least two children
out of the uh several that were injured
at least two of them are in a critical
condition this is just a a terrible
thing to have happened and to children
as you said some of them as young as
three or three years old one eyewitness
saying that she saw the man also lunging
at children in a pram so people
incredibly shocked here in France MPS in
France's national assembly had a minute
silence and the French President uh
Emmanuel macron has called this attack
cowardly and I can imagine that many
people will agree with them as they try
to absorb this violence that has
happened as I said with such young
people so vulnerable just children just
awful Natasha Butler there with the
latest for us from Paris thank you
Natasha